well according to the interior minister  of ukraine rebels have shot down that  malaysian air triple seven that was on  route from amsterdam to kuala lumpur so  again this is ukrainian interior  minister previously it was Interfax  reporting this the ukrainian interior  minister says that there were two  hundred eighty eight passengers onboard  that Malaysian triple seven and 15 crew  they say it was shot down near done yet  square ukrainian government troops are  fighting rebels so again the ukrainian  interior minister saying that rebels  have shot down that malaysian air flight  flying from amsterdam to kuala lumpur  will continue of course to monitor the  situation and bring you updates eric  does appear to be moving the market  stocks are now selling off on news again  that this triple seven was shot down  according to the interior minister by  rebels near done yet